encore un peu de patience pour les fanas
de technologie le fameux iphone d'apple
sera officiellement en vente en fin
d'après midi en france c'est vraiment un
téléphone intelligent de nouvelle
génération nous avons voulu savoir ce
qu'il avait de plus que ses concurrents
mais aussi pointé ses défauts le premier
c'est peut-être son prix c'est le
dossier du 13 heures
il est signé jean paul chapelle et
frédéric bazille approvisionnement sous
haute surveillance dans cette boutique
des champs elysées on a livré un millier
d'appareils
objet de toutes les convoitises comptés
et recomptés
et puis après 300 des dix cerveaux il
faut pas en perdre en confort rappelle
399 euros avec abonnement
un abonnement qui démarre à 49 euros par
mois pour quatre heures de
communications téléphoniques mais ce
téléphone c'est aussi un baladeur
musical et un album photos qu'on
feuillette grâce à son écran tactile
pouvez en plus fondée l'appareil et un
abonnement orange offre des services
inédits en france comme la messagerie
vocale visuelle
au lieu d'écouter vos messages mais là
vous les écouter mais en plus vous les
voyez mais je peux par exemple écouter
directement le message de caroline d'une
quatrième directement avant le premier
l'iphone débarque ce soir sur les champs
elysées quelques mètres plus bas
les concurrents ont déjà préparé la
contre attaque et pour 200 euros de moi
vous avez un produit plus efficace
appareil photo numérique lecteur mp3
vous pouvez même avoir vos vidéos à
l'intérieur et vous avez un superbe
navigateur gps gps mais surtout un accès
à internet deux fois plus rapide que sur
l'iphone car ici c'est le réseau haut
débit de troisième génération l'arrivée
de l'iphone marque aussi une nouvelle
étape dans le commerce
le client doit s'inscrire sur le
logiciel de apple qui va nous facturer
directement des musiques pour commencer
on a déjà acheté le sont mais on a déjà
acheté un titre musical on veut
l'utiliser en sonnerie on paie une
deuxième fois on paie un euro pour
utiliser un titre qu'on a déjà payé un
euro auparavant
dans son téléphone un supermarché
ambulant c'est ce que pourraient devenir
demain
ce téléphone pour le vendre en
exclusivité le patron de france télécom
a accepté de payer apple une partie de
ses revenus sans doute 30%
effectivement il ya un partage de
revenus
le détail je vous le donnerai pas ce que
c'est le secret du contrat j'ai pas de
vous le dire j'ai pas le soleil tort la
raison pour laquelle je fais ça c'est
parce que c'est l'union de deux marques
qui sont les premières mondiales chacune
dans leur domaine
on pourra cependant acheter l'iphone ou
sans abonnement en france mais plus cher
749 euros ou la version mobile
d'internet